when you're writing fiction what's your
first name hi Maddie she said when when
you're writing fiction how do you create
character and how do you avoid creating
same old character yeah that's a hard
one next question for mr. Kane you write
a lot about this in on writing I think
that I think that the way that I would
answer that is first of all you start
with the idea that for most of us we
think that we're we're good guys we
think we're the good guys we think we're
on the side of angels and so my idea is
everybody has some part of their
character that's admirable
I'm sure that at one time or another
Theodore Bundy helped an old lady across
the street
of course he probably raped and murdered
her on the other side but that's that
what I'm talking about
that's the yin and yang of it so I have
a tendency to start totally unknown I'm
and that's that that's part of the
benefit of working story rather than
plot our lives developed naturally and
our characters develop naturally over a
period of time and they are influenced
by a lot of different characteristics
and the way that we look at other people
is influenced to over a period of time
as we get to know them sometimes women
that you didn't think we're you know
particularly good-looking you get to
know them the more you see them the more
you say after a while you say oh that
woman is pretty and then a year or two
later you say that woman is really
beautiful but I didn't see that at first
you say some guy well he's just a guy
and he sort of just somebody else that
happened to be at this party or in this
dorm or whatever and you get to talk to
those people a little bit the
personality starts to come forward and
you start to see the shadows and the
depth of things I've got
character and mr. Mercedes whose name is
Holly give me and I expected it to be a
walk-on ok she's this 47 year old woman
who still lives with her aging mother
and she's got psychological problems and
she never speaks above a a mumble in
fact she's introduced in the book is
Holly the mumbler
because she's one of these people we've
seen this person we've all seen this
person you can't really say what they're
saying you can't really hear what they
are saying and they have a tendency to
sort of avoid eye contact they might
look up every now and then a little bit
they might have certain tics habits so I
thought to myself well I've got a great
line for this this this lady the first
time that my main character meets her is
at a Holiday Inn restaurant where he
thinks she orders a sneeze burger
because she speaks so low she's actually
ordering a cheeseburger so I thought she
was a walk-on I thought she was a flat
character little by little she's become
more and more important to me and more
fun to write about and I started to see
that she has an interior life and you
begin by observing we I mean you have to
lick raise your hand again if you're in
the writing courses you have to look you
have to see I mean you can't just walk
and let it all go by it's somebody some
of this has got to stay you've got to
see how people are you've got to look
for the person who when they eat they
have a tendency to look down at their
plate and they're tearing their napkins
have you ever seen a napkin Ripper
okay or somebody who's in a cafeteria
and they've kind of like got the straw
in pieces holly is a lipstick biter kind
of like
this all the time kind of rock mMmmm
she'll talk through her nails so I it's
it's part of the fun of it to me it's to
see better and see more you know that
famous a Connor line about this she says
there's a certain grain of stupidity the
writer can hardly do without yeah and
then as the quality of having to stare
yeah so you're hearing you say for
everybody is that when you create
character you're really fueled by
curiosity not answers that's right you
want to see them grow and they do their
own thing if you let them if you let
them do their own thing and one of the
things that drives me crazy about second
and third grade fiction is when a writer
will wind the character up and make them
go through certain paces and I think why
don't you just go back and cut out paper
dolls